Lada Mir Putin will be holding a State
of the Nation Address in the next two
days do we expect any kind of movements
before them what would you look for for
mr. Putin I think he's yeah his
instincts are to hang tough he's got to
speak to a domestic party but you
remember when he was just recently in
Brisbane he went to the g20 meeting
there that the Australians health and
supposedly from all my Russian friends
what I heard was he was stunned by how
isolated he was this guy lives in a
cocoon an approval is so important yeah
but yeah if you get expression shoot the
messenger and Russia is not just an
expression I think he is really isolate
bastard I don't want to pin you down but
you've got a lot of people you can throw
this to and your CFR is his leadership
his tenure his whatever you want to call
it is it threatened by these financial
moves at the moment no his numbers are
still stunningly high every other leader
in the world you know we get part of his
Anatomy for Putin's numbers he's still
well up in the 80s so the real question
is though you know does this begin to
take its toll but we haven't seen signs
of it yet but no matter you know what
where his approval numbers are you know
Russians are beginning to embrace
reality in a small way shopkeepers are
now denominating their purchases or
their sales in nominal units which is a
euphemism for a dollar so they're
starting to adjust right oh absolutely
and this is gonna cause massive
inflation you know Russia doesn't have
an enormous amount I gather of
dollar-denominated debt but it's to make
it impossible for them to go into
markets to raise money there this this
will have its toll gradually and the
real question is when does Putin begin
to adjust